avant de commencer la vidéo j'aimerais
remercier notre partenariat du jour il
m'accompagne depuis quelques temps
maintenant et c'est un produit que
j'utilise au quotidien vous l'aurez
compris cette vidéo est sponsorisée par
norvpn êtes-vous intéressé pour voir ou
revoir les récents films Marvel depuis
chez vous et au chaud que ce soit
Docteur Strange 2 Thor love and sender
ou bien même Black Panther ou acanda
Forever qui sera sur la plateforme dès
janvier et bien c'est possible grâce à
norvpn en un seul clic vous pouvez
changer la localisation de votre
ordinateur pour accéder au contenu d'un
autre pays je vous avoue que c'est très
pratique pour voir les films qui ne sont
pas disponibles en France et comme vous
le savez certains contenus bougent et
changent de plateforme donc quand vous
utilisez nordvpn vous pouvez toujours
voir des œuvres qui ont disparu d'une
plateforme en France mais qui le sont
toujours dans un autre pays bref norvpn
est un outil très utile et je me dois
quand même de vous rappeler à quel point
ce dernier est sécurisé grâce à lui vous
serez protégé contre les criminels et la
surveillance sur le web on n'oublie pas
de mentionner que nordvpn possède
également une excellente vitesse
d'exécution grâce à ses 5200 serveurs
répartis dans plus de 60 pays et que
c'est disponible sur 6 appareils
différents donc de quoi en faire
profiter les potes si vous êtes
intéressé un lien est disponible dans la
description et n'hésitez pas à profiter
de l'offre exceptionnelle de deux ans
d'abonnement avec une très grosse
réduction et 4 mois offerts tout ça
satisfait ou remboursé sur 30 jours
encore merci à nordvpn que la vidéo
commence
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo qui on ne va pas se
mentir est un petit peu particulière je
vais me confier à vous j'ai vraiment
envie d'évoluer d'avancer et d'améliorer
le contenu de mes vidéos alors cela peut
être un petit peu bateau pour beaucoup
d'entre vous mais en relativisant de mon
côté j'aimerais que mes vidéos soient
plus complètes et plus approfondie
concernant l'univers Marvel je
m'explique vous êtes beaucoup tous les
jours à me poser des questions sur
l'univers Marvel que ce soit les comics
ou encore les films slash séries et
c'est normal nous arrivons à la phase 5
du Marvel cinématique Universe la saga
du multivers est lancée et cela ne va
pas aller en simplification bien au
contraire la saga de l'infini la
finalité c'était l'arrivée de Thanos
avec les 6 pierres désormais dans les
nouvelles phases nous sommes tournés
vers le multivers et c'est un concept
plutôt particulier puisqu'il faut
prendre en compte les voyages dans le
temps le concept de dimension ou encore
l'unité de réalité alternative bref que
des choses qui ne sont pas aussi simples
que l'on pourrait penser en plus de cela
il ne faut pas oublier et négliger le
fait que le MCU avance et par conséquent
ces personnages aussi et il commence à y
en avoir pas mal donc bon ce n'est pas
simple du tout à assimiler et de suivre
mais justement c'est là où moi
j'aimerais m'améliorer et peut-être me
prouver des choses aussi je pense j'ai
envie de bien vous faire comprendre
l'univers Marvel et du coup bah c'est là
que vous intervenez malgré selon speech
je suis désolé si cela vous a ennuyé
mais j'aimerais que l'on revienne du
coup sur le cas de Kang le Conquérant
dans Ant-Man cantumania parce qu'en vrai
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire il y a
vraiment plein de questions auxquelles
nous devons trouver des réponses et on
n'a pas eu le temps de vraiment
détailler tout ça dans la vidéo
d'analyse de trailer néanmoins vu que
j'aspire à ce que vous appreniez des
choses j'ai eu l'idée de faire un post
sur Youtube où je vous demandais s'il y
avait des choses que vous ne compreniez
pas par exemple sur kangle conquérant
s'il y avait des éléments qui que vous
trouviez un petit peu flou que vous
aimeriez avoir des explications alors
sur la base de vos questions un petit
peu à la manière d'une FAQ nous allons
tenter d'éclaircir du coup tout ce qui
entoure Kang dans le MCU et quand même
plus particulièrement le Kang de Ant-Man
quantumania vous voyez cette vidéo si
vous le voulez comme une sorte de
nouveau concept même si cela traduit
plutôt une sorte de Nouvelair où
j'aimerais que les vidéos soient quand
même un petit peu plus complète et
approfondi et ah oui juste un dernier
mot puis après on va commencer
j'aimerais vous inviter à voir ma vidéo
dédiée à l'histoire de Kang le
Conquérant dans les comics avant de voir
celle-ci car même si nous allons revenir
sur des éléments de la vie du personnage
pour éclaircir certaines zones d'ombre
voilà je ne serai jamais aussi complet
que dans la vidéo que je vous conseille
pour comprendre justement qui est le
personnage sur ce à cette blabla si vous
êtes prêts on y va
une fois là bas vous allez à la
rencontre de la personne qui est en
train d'écrire ce fameux livre sauf que
vous l'empêchez de l'écrire et bien à ce
moment-là un paradoxe se crée puisque
normalement il aurait dû écrire le livre
et le sortir en 1981 mais à cause de vos
actions ce n'est pas arrivé du coup
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe et bien à ce
moment une nouvelle branche se crée
l'histoire c'est déjà déroulé le livre a
déjà été écrit cependant rappelez-vous
on ne peut pas modifier le passé ce qui
est fait est fait donc une nouvelle
Timeline se lance à partir de ce moment
et cela crée ce que la série Loki a
nommé un Nexus maintenant si nous
revenons sur Kang la particularité
propre du personnage vous le savez c'est
le voyage dans le temps Kang est un
conquérant des époques et autres
temporalités alors quand il voyage dans
le passé et qu'il modifie quelque chose
cela crée un Nexus une nouvelle branche
et je vous dirais que c'est même quelque
chose qui va lui péter au visage dans
les comics Kang n'en avait pas
spécialement en conscience là-bas mais
c'est nombreux voyages ont donné
naissance à une multitude d'autres Kangs
car en voulant conquérir le passé ou
changer les événements prévus ce dernier
a en fait donné naissance à de nouvelles
réalités en fait intégrer que c'est
comme ça que le multivers est né et
fonctionne tout part à chaque fois d'un
Nexus vous avez votre tram principal un
Nexus apparaît une nouvelle réalité est
née et nous pouvons continuer comme ça
indéfiniment tout ça permet du coup de
nous proposer une infinité de variétés
d'univers prenons l'exemple de Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of my Ness le
producteur nous a partagé la possibilité
que le Nexus qui a engendré l'univers
838 serait la réussite de la création
d'ultron par Tony Stark par conséquent
vu qu'il tronc et fonctionnel les
Avengers n'ont plus besoin de travailler
alors ils ont pris leur retraite et à
terme cela a donné naissance au groupe
secret des illuminatis bref nous
commençons à nous égarer mais imag ce
fonctionnement avec le personnage de
Kang Kang à cause de ses voyages crée
une multitude d'autres Kangs des
variants et ces derniers vu qu'il voyage
aussi dans le temps donne naissance à
d'autres Kangs etc etc
deuxième question pourquoi quand est
dans le royaume quantique de quel
univers il provient et quid de la guerre
multiverselle et de celui qui demeure
dans l'eau qui alors dans ce cas de
figure nous sommes plus sur un aspect
théorique du coup je vais vous proposer
ma vision personnelle des choses puisque
nous n'avons pas encore officiellement
les réponses tout d'abord il faut mettre
les choses au clair il n'y a pas un
royaume quantique mais il y en a
plusieurs les royaumes quantiques ne
sont pas des univers mais des dimensions
des dimensions qui sont accessibles
depuis la Terre grâce aux particules de
handpim qui vous permet de modifier
votre taille vers l'infiniment petit
pour faire plus simple voyez ça comme
une gigantesque dimension à plusieurs
étages ou plusieurs secteurs si vous
préférez et autres éléments très
important Avengers endgame nous a
démontré que le royaume quantique est
lié à plusieurs temporalités de par ses
nombreux tunnels durant leur caste
temporel Tony Stark a permis aux
Avengers de changer d'époque et de
revenir dans le présent par le biais du
royaume quantique du coup rien qu'avec
cela pour moi c'est clair comme de l'eau
de roche concernant Kang mais bon je
peux me tromper nous sommes face pour
moi au Kang le conquérant de la réalité
6016 c'est-à-dire la réalité principale
que nous suivons via les films et séries
alors pourquoi cela premièrement si nous
suivons la logique et les règles que je
vous ai énoncées depuis le début le
royaume quantique n’est en rien lié au
multivers ce dernier est relié au voyage
dans le temps or c'est là toute la
subtilité car le Royaume quantique
permet seulement de changer d'époque et
de temporalité et ce qui va donner
naissance à une autre réalité une autre
branche ce sont les actions des
personnages dans d'autres termes la
création d'un Nexus et c'est là que
c'est pertinent 40 man vise ses
aventures dans l'univers 616 nous sommes
dans la continuité d'Avengers endgame et
Don man donc logiquement si Ant-Man se
retrouve face à Kang dans le royaume
quantique il s'agit pour moi du Kang de
l'univers 616 est-ce que vous comprenez
ce que je veux dire d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est très important de le rajouter
mais Ant-Man quantumania va nous
proposer la première véritable
apparition de Kang le Conquérant à
l'écran ce qui veut dire que tout comme
Namor par exemple dans Black Panther ou
Wakanda Forever ou encore America Chavez
dans Docteur Strange 2 Marvel va nous
introduire le personnage cela va être un
premier aperçu ils vont nous donner
possiblement une origine story donc
voilà on ne peut pas faire face
directement à un suprême Kang qui a déjà
tout vu tout vécu surtout qu'en plus on
l'a déjà eu dans Loki Kang à l'origine
dans les comics c'est simplement un gars
qui voyage dans le temps et qui
conquiert les époques il n'a rien à voir
avec le multivers à la base il va en
prendre conscience bien plus tard une
fois de voyage temporels effectués il
faut que Marvel construisent l'histoire
de Kang dans les films et pour cela il
nous faut un Kang à l'aube de son
histoire je vous le dis comparer cela à
d'autres personnages il faut y aller
crescendo americachavez ne fait pas de
Gigaro trip dans le multivers en
fonction de ses souhaits alors que
pourtant bah c'est ce qu'elle fait dans
les comics non ils prennent le temps
d'introduire le personnage et les
concepts qui l'entourent America Chavez
prend le temps de comprendre son pouvoir
et elle fera des dingueries bien plus
tard là c'est pareil avec Kang il faut
que le spectateur lambda comprenne le
personnage qui il est pourquoi il se
fait nommer Kang le Conquérant quels
sont ses pouvoirs et bien plus tard nous
aurons les enjeux du multivers et tout
ce qui s'ensuit du coup par rapport à ce
que je disais pour moi dans ant man nous
allons faire face au kangle conquérant
de la réalité 616 et par rapport au
comics son origine story colle
parfaitement avec cette idée normalement
celui qui se fait appeler Kang est à
l'origine Nathaniel Richards et c'est un
brillant scientifique du 31ème siècle ce
dernier va découvrir les travaux du
docteur doum qui est le premier
personnage des comics à avoir découvert
le voyage dans le temps et basé sur les
travaux de ce dernier Nathaniel va
appréhender puis comprendre le voyage
dans le temps et va commencer à voyager
jusqu'à changer d'identité à plusieurs
reprises et devenir à terme Kang le
Conquérant là par rapport à ce qui a été
instauré dans le MCU nous pourrions
faire sensiblement la même chose
c'est-à-dire que et c'est une vieille
théorie que je vous avais proposé à
l'époque mais en gros que Kang aurait
découvert les travaux de Tony Stark
depuis son lointain futur et vu que les
travaux de Tony concernant le voyage
dans le temps sont basés sur le chant
quantique et bien Kang ferait la même
chose donc voilà pour moi quantumania va
nous proposer un kangle conquérant qui
sait déjà expérimenté sur le voyage dans
le temps puisque Nathaniel quand il
devient Kang il maîtrise déjà
parfaitement le voyage dans le temps et
surtout que Kang et Kang parce qu'il a
voyagé sans le faire exprès dans le 41e
siècle et cela lui a permis d'obtenir et
comprendre la technologie de ce lointain
futur et grâce à ça il a pu développer
énormément d'armements sa propre armure
ou bien même chronopolis sa capitale et
tout ça ce sont des choses que nous
retrouvons dans le trailer alors
maintenant concernant celui qui demeure
tout ça c'est encore très loin pour moi
quant au Mania est avant tout une
introduction pour l'identité et le
personnage de Kang le Conquérant tout ce
qui est guère multiversel etc ce sera
pour bien plus tard néanmoins il est
clair pour moi que ce Kang dans
quantumania aura son rôle à jouer dans
le futur et prendra certainement par à
la future guerre multiverselle car oui
vous l'aurez peut-être compris mais nous
sommes face à une boucle les événements
de Loki sont en fait la fin de
l'histoire celui qui demeure est le
grand gagnant de la guerre multivers et
pour protéger l'univers d'une autre
guerre il a isolé le flux temporel et
grâce au TVA il supprime les Nexus pour
éviter que le multivers se relance et du
coup que de nouveaux Kangs apparaissent
pour [ __ ] le bordel sauf qu'avec sa
mort plus personne ne compte s'occuper
des Nexus et du coup c'est le retour du
multivers et des nombreuses réalités par
conséquent l'arrivée d'autres variants
de celui qui demeure qui vont vouloir
conquérir les autres univers bref une
nouvelle guerre multiverselle quoi
néanmoins voilà il faut y aller par
étape il faut développer Kang et ses
nombreuses identités son histoire et à
terme nous pourrons entamer la guerre
multiverselle en vrai j'aimerais faire
quand même un petit point un petit
aparté là concernant celui qui demeure
j'ai remarqué que vous étiez pas mal
avoir des interrogations le concernant
néanmoins nous sommes dans une vidéo où
nous sommes quand même plutôt dédiés au
camp de conquérant de quantumania celui
qui demeure mériterait en vrai d'avoir
sa propre vidéo donc à envie de me dire
si cela vous dit et je serai ravi de le
faire par contre je me dis que c'est
quand même intéressant de faire un petit
point vite fait le concernant par
rapport au camp de quantumania d'où
l'aparté du coup celui qui demeure et le
kangle de quantumania ne sont pas les
mêmes personnes pour moi et cela nous
éprouvait visuellement concernant les
personnages Kang dans Ant-Man possède
des cicatrices sur son visage élément
visuels qui pour moi permet de le
différencier de celui qui demeure
normalement c'est cicatrices n'existent
pas dans les comics donc c'est un apport
au film pour que les spectateurs ne
confondent pas les identités de Kang
bref je ne m'étale pas celui qui demeure
il y a quand même beaucoup de choses à
dire le concernant mais nous en avons
déjà assez avec quantumania
troisième question si il est le grand
méchant de la saga du multivers pourquoi
est-ce qu'il semble être le méchant
principal de ce Ant-Man je pensais qu'il
serait tisé ici et là comme Thanos à
l'époque mais il a l'air d'être très
présent déjà cette question est très
intéressante car elle révèle pour moi la
stratégie de Marvel concernant le
personnage Kang possède une
particularité propre comparée aux autres
vilains ce sont ces nombreuses
identités en fait parce que c'est un
voyageur temporel nous ne savons jamais
qui nous avons en face de nous et
justement c'est là que les identités
interviennent les identités de Nathaniel
Richards nous permettent de comprendre
qui nous avons en face de nous sans
avoir à raconter à chaque fois
l'histoire du personnage dans les comics
je vais détailler pour que ce soit plus
clair Nathaniel Richards va avoir
plusieurs identités au travers de sa vie
et de ses voyages temporels à tel point
que nous aurons l'impression que ce sont
des personnages complètement différents
au départ il est le brillant
scientifique du 31e siècle puis une fois
que le voyage j'entends sera appréhendé
il ira dans l’égypte antique où il va
s'ériger en tant que Pharaon à ce moment
il va prendre l'identité de ramatout
après sa rencontre avec le docteur Doom
il va s'inspirer de ce dernier croyant
qu'il est son ancêtre et il va devenir
Scarlet centurion puis quand il va subir
sa cuisante défaite en tant que Scarlet
centurion et après s'être perdu dans le
temps pour atterrir dans le 41e siècle
il va devenir Kang le conquérant et
quand il en aura marre de ses conquêtes
il va redevenir ramatout enfin quand il
comprendra que son lui du passé devenu
Kang et trop dangereux il va s'allier au
thème Keepers pour le combattre et
deviendra l'entité sage Immortus
souverain des limbes et maître du temps
et j'ai omis de parler d'ironlade qui
est Nathaniel adolescence lâche jeune
adulte qui approchait par son lui du
futur en tant que Kang va devenir un
super héros pour combattre le Conquérant
j'ai essayé de synthétiser au maximum
mais voilà c'est pour que vous ayez
toutes les cartes en main en fait
est importante car elle marque des
moments précis de la vie de Nathaniel et
du coup cela nous permet de discerner
complètement qui nous avons en face de
nous celui qui demeure est le souverain
du temps qui empêche les autres Kangs
d'intervenir et il est logé à la fin des
temps ok nous sommes face à Immortus la
dernière identité de Nathaniel qui a
tout vécu Kang apparaît dans Ant-Man
quantumania d'accord cela veut dire que
le personnage est déjà adulte il a déjà
parcouru le 41e siècle normalement il a
déjà conquis des temporalités il a sa
propre armée sa technologie etc etc
est-ce que vous comprenez le
fonctionnement et le truc c'est que du
coup chaque
identité est hyper importante ces
limites si chaque identité ne possède
pas sa propre histoire c'est presque des
personnages complètement différents en
fait iron lad par exemple est un jeune
garçon qui veut faire le bien il est
même celui qui va concevoir l'équipe des
Young Avengers a contrario kangle
conquérant est l'identité la dangereuse
c'est le moment où Nathaniel est le plus
armé où il a le plus de conviction et de
pouvoir Immortus et plutôt quelqu'un
tourner vers le bon fonctionnement du
temps et de l'univers il est beaucoup
plus neutre il est capable d'affronter
les Avengers comme de les aider ce qui
compte c'est le bon déroulement du temps
bref tout ça pour dire que dans ant Man
3 je pense que Kang aura de l'importance
dans son rôle et sa présence dans le
film tout simplement car Marvel souhaite
pour la première fois nos introduire
l'identité de Kang le Conquérant tout
comme ils ont introduit l'identité
d'immortus renommée cette fois-ci en
celui qui demeure dans la série de Loki
et à mon avis bah ils vont continuer
comme ça jusqu'aux événements de
Avengers the Kang dynastie ils vont
introduire une à une les grandes
identités de Nathaniel pour que nous
soyons familiers avec chacune d'entre
elles puis après ça ça partira en guerre
donc en relativisant c'est une certaines
formes de teasing ils amènent petit à
petit les
identités
quatrième question mais du coup qu'en
est-il de motoc oui le trailer a
complètement laissé Modock de côté pour
celles et ceux qui ne savent pas mode
doc et censés être le véritable vilain
du film Kang n'est censé être
normalement qu'un personnage secondaire
alors bref Origins story de Modock
histoire que nous soyons tous sur un
même pied d'égalité modoch au
commencement c'est un homme il s'appelle
George Tarleton et c'est un simple
technicien du groupe très secret appelé
ame ou advanceidy mécanics cette
association malfaisante est un petit peu
un équivalent d'Hydra sauf que leur but
est comme leur nom l'indique la création
de technologie
ultra avancée et développé du coup pas
en revenir à Georges ce dernier sera
victime d'un des nombreux projets de
lame ces derniers sont en train de
développer un cube cosmique permettant
d'altérer la réalité et possédant des
capacités infinies néanmoins le travail
est trop conséquent on surpasse
clairement les la connaissance de
l'humanité par conséquent la solution
est de donner naissance à une entité
capable d'analyser et sonder le cube
sous tous les angles H24 ce qui
permettra d'augmenter la productivité et
alléger les efforts scientifiques
Georges simple technicien sera alors
désigné pour devenir le projet modoch un
homme qui va devenir un super ordinateur
vivant malheureusement pour les
scientifiques de lame en créant une
entité aux capacités à l'intelligence
supérieure modoch va naturellement
devenir mégalomane et va commencer à
ressentir une ambition qui dépasse celle
des simples mortels modoch va donc se
rebeller et annihiler ses créateurs
avant de prendre le contrôle de lame par
rapport au MCU maintenant comment relier
mot doc et Kang et du coup Ant-Man
quantumania de par certaines
informations relatées concernant le film
ainsi que le trailer nous savons kantman
va travailler pour Kang le Conquérant
comme démontré Scott et son équipe vont
se retrouver bloqué dans le royaume
quantique et Kang aurait apparemment les
moyens de le faire rentrer chez lui sauf
que comme il le dit lui-même c'est
donnant donnant donc Ant-Man va devoir
faire quelque chose pour Kang en échange
de rentrer chez lui et c'est là que
c'est intrigant car qu'est-ce qui
pourrait intéresser Kang et pourquoi
Ant-Man est si utile à ses yeux surtout
que vu que nous savons que modoch et le
méchant du film cela veut dire qu'il y a
quelque chose en lien avec modo qui
pourrait intéresser Kang le Conquérant
ou alors que modoch est également
intéressé par la même chose que quand le
Conquérant je vous avoue que tout ça
cela me gratte un peu la tête car il y a
énormément de possibilités et de
réécriture le cas de figure le plus
probable celui que tout le monde pense
Kang est bloqué dans le chant quantique
en fait déjà cela expliquerait pourquoi
ce dernier n'est jamais intervenu
auparavant mais surtout élément très
intéressant cela pourrait donner une
réécriture possible de son histoire dans
ses aventures cela arrive que Nathaniel
se retrouve bloquée intemporairement à
cause de ces voyages temporels ce qui
fait qu'il se retrouve en quelque sorte
prisonniers entre guillemets très vite
fait d'une époque et un moment qui
traduit parfaitement cette idée c'est
quand il va atterrir sans faire exprès
au 41e siècle là-bas il va découvrir un
monde en ruine ou l'humanité est en
pleine auto-destruction cependant c'est
également durant cette période qu'il va
découvrir les nombreuses avancées
technologiques du futur et grâce à cela
il va pouvoir donner naissance à son
identité de Kang le Conquérant par
rapport au MCU ce ne serait pas
impossible que Kang en découvrant les
voyages temporels c'est retrouver bloqué
dans le royaume quantique sauf qu'en
découvrant ce nouveau monde il a fait la
découverte de gens au savoir inconnus de
l'humanité et ce serait là-bas qu'il a
pris l'identité de Kang le conquérant et
qu'il aurait apprivoisé une toute
nouvelle technologie inconnue sur terre
et par conséquent c'est comme ça qu'il
créé chronopolis dans le royaume
quantique comme je vous l'expliquais
auparavant le royaume quantique est une
dimension énorme divisée en plusieurs
étages ou plusieurs secteurs il se
pourrait alors qu'en première étape Kang
est devenu un conquérant en essayant
d'assouvir l'entièreté du royaume
quantique et que du coup par le biais
d'antan et de Modock il ne lui reste
qu'un pas pour passer à l'étape
supérieure accéder au monde réel et
l'envahir mais revenons plus
particulièrement sur modo que car j'ai
de belles informations et théorie à vous
fournir normalement dans les comics Kang
et modoch n'ont rien à voir cependant
pour le MCU en réalité il ne pourrait y
avoir qu'un pas premièrement l'origine
story de modoch peut-être adapté à celle
de Kang le Conquérant c'est une théorie
que je vous ai déjà rapidement partagé
mais en gros modoch est un humain
génétiquement modifié en super
ordinateur dû aux actions de brillant
scientifique orientés dans la
technologie comment vous dire que Kang
est un brillant scientifique et un
véritable expert de la technologie ce
dernier pour le MCU pourrait
complètement être le créateur de MODOK
qui au final ce serait rebeller comme
dans les comics contre son créateur en
plus de cela il y a une question qui
mérite d'être soulignée c'est que le
film se déroulerait entièrement dans le
royaume quantique du coup si modoch est
le méchant du film il serait également
dans la dimension alors pourquoi je
pense ça et bien tout simplement du fait
cantman est bloqué dans le champ
quantique sans pouvoir le quitter mais
surtout car Kang et là-bas aussi en fait
ce que je trouve incohérent ce serait
l'idée que Kang puisse sortir du champ
quantique tout seul parce que si c'est
le cas pourquoi quand tout Mania en fait
Kang aurait déjà envahi des temporalités
et surtout si il a le moyen de voyager
tout seul il est en capacité de
développer son équipement pour à terme
amener son armée et ses armes avec lui
rien ne pourrait véritablement le
freiner il a besoin de tel AR
mais cela ne s'arrête pas là
effectivement après analyse des
minutesmaines cet objet proviendrait du
troisième millénaire et d'après
l'analyse de la base de données du TVA
cette pelle aurait été fabriquée par
lame et là c'est juste fou car oui lame
aurait dû se stopper avec Iron Man 3
mais ce passage dans la série Loki nous
prouve que l'organisation a perpétué et
ce jusqu'à au moins l'an 3000 je vous
avoue que cela remet pas mal de choses
en perspective car comme nous l'avons
découvert dans la série Loki le TVA
possède une technologie extrêmement
avancée Sylvie ne se sert que d'artefact
voler au TVA et vu les révélations de la
fin de la série c'est invariant de Kang
qui a conçu cette entreprise du coup je
vous le mets dans le mille mais est-ce
que kangle conquérant ne serait pas au
final relié à lame en fait tout comme la
réécriture possible sur l'histoire de
Kang que je vous annonçais auparavant il
se pourrait qu'il y ait encore une fois
une réécriture ici Kong dans le aurait
possiblement atteint un stade avancé de
technologie qui lui aurait permis de se
développer dans le champ quantique grâce
aux travaux de lame contrairement au
comics ou c'est le 41e siècle qui lui a
apporté tout ce savoir mais je pense
qu'il faut que je sois un petit peu plus
clair essayons de réagir
chronologiquement parlant si je
récapitule la théorie Nathaniel est né
au 31ème siècle il est un brillant
scientifique qui va découvrir le voyage
dans le temps grâce aux travaux de Tony
Stark une fois dans le royaume quantique
Nathaniel dompte cette nouvelle
dimension et les nouveaux savoirs qui
lui sont apportés et devient Kang le
Conquérant une fois tout ça il crée
chronopolis son quartier général où il
planifie ses conquêtes il crée motoc
bref il se développe et tout ça grâce à
la technologie et au savoir développer
par lame après est-ce que Kang a
apprivoisé la technologie de lame parce
qu'il travaille avec eux dans le futur
ou bien parce que l'ame était déjà dans
le royaume quantique avant Nathaniel
cela reste encore à définir mais par la
suite vu que un Kang va devenir celui
qui demeure et elle créateur du TVA et
que lui et ses variants sont tous
sensiblement pareil cela veut donc dire
que la technologie de lame est une
technologie qui va aider à développer le
TVA et ainsi de suite enfin bon c'est
juste de la théorie mais bon c'est
toujours un vrai plaisir de chercher
dans les petits détails pour deviner le
MCU
et écoutez je pense que cela va être la
fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous
aura apporté certaines réponses bien
évidemment cela ne traduit que ma pensée
et mes interprétations peut-être que
tout ce que j'ai dit mes théories seront
fausses mais le but c'est avant tout
pour que vous appreniez des choses sur
quand le Conquérant ce n'est pas dit que
l'on ne recommence pas l'exercice de
faire une vidéo sur Kang parce qu'en
vrai il y a vraiment beaucoup de choses
à dire il y a beaucoup de pistes mais
voilà nous pourrons le faire en temps
voulu j'espère que la vidéo vous aura
plu n'hésitez pas à me faire un maximum
de retour en commentaire et à partager
vos avis vos théories et puis bah vos
questions je tenterai de répondre si
vous avez des interrogations sur ce
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner n'oubliez
pas non plus de laisser un pouce bleu
qui me soutient beaucoup c'était
argorock que le lion hard soit avec vous
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]